this morning we have a close-up look at
the us-led war against Isis in Syria
Charlie d'Agata is about 150 miles from
Mon Beach near one of the last Isis
strongholds he went on patrol with
Kurdish forces supported by US troops
who say the fight against the terrorist
organization is far from over
while President Trump and vice-president
pence continue to insist that Isis is
defeated in Syria the frontlines tell a
much different story with US forces in
their allies on the ground
battling a persistent enemy that refuses
to surrender even as we made our way to
the fighting we were warned that Isis
terror cells lurked among the ruined
villages launching counter-attacks and
planting bombs on the only Road in and
out we're now traveling to the
frontlines in the east of the country
the very last pockets of Isis resistance
now once these areas are taken back Isis
will no longer be considered a
territorial force here we arrived at
Ashraf to see Kurdish LED forces firing
a barrage of mortars toward Isis
positions not much more than a mile away
and nearby vital reinforcements US
troops and military hardware not more
than a few hundred yards away is where
you find an American position fighting
right beside forces here and they've
been firing mortars in that direction
essentially since we got here how
important is it for you to have American
forces on the ground fighting right
beside you they're playing a very big
role commander Simcoe shock told us
their forces have been very effective we
give them coordinates for Isis locations
and their air force and artillery do all
they can in addition to roughly 2000 US
ground forces here the american-led air
campaign has been pummeling this
territory 575 air strikes on 1,100
targets during the first two weeks of
this
alone concentrated on a sliver of land
still under Isis control commanders here
tell us that final push could take a
month or more but as the tragic deaths
of four Americans and more than a dozen
others in man-bird shows isis is already
morphed into an insurgency that has
begun striking targets far beyond these
battlefields for CBS this morning
Charlie d'Agata in eastern Syria